[Music]
hello I am Alexis Nicole Nelson and we
are here in my backyard in Scenic
Columbus Ohio y'all want to see a huge
mushroom o my mom who's like such an
avid Gardener when she would work in the
garden I would usually be tasked with
going and finding the edible weeds
around our yard to bring in and add to
dinner lunch snacks what have you she
had developed a lot of her love of
plants from her mother my nana so she
really got to pass that love of growing
things and plants in General on to my
mom who then passed it down onto
me I'm using ocean water to pickle these
beads so I just developed this near
obsession with snackable plants that
really followed me all the way into
adulthood
and in terms of social media I mean as a
younger Millennial I was pretty much
raised by the internet in part I think
internet was all of our third parents
unbeknownst to me until way later in
life had kind of been honing getting
better at making good content things
that people want to read things that
people want to watch things that people
want to share and then when I had my
marketing job at bark I really really
got to hone my skills there because if
you can make content that can sell
things you can honestly make good
content that does anything else I'd say
a year or two into my time at bark I had
started posting on what at that time was
a Fina of mine because I was worried
about bothering my friends and my family
with all of my plant nonsense in my
posts and in my Instagram stories so I
decided one day I'm just going to make a
plant Fina
and I was deciding what name to choose
and I was lamenting to my boss she also
forages and she was just like oh well
you were talking about how you feel like
you don't see a lot of people who look
like you out in the world of foraging
online so maybe it should speak to that
and I was like oh yeah you're right I'm
just going to call myself black
forager and I started posting mostly
essays and you know still
photos and as time progressed Tik Tok
kind of came into the picture and I just
tested a million different things and
got more comfy with video editing and
having my face in content and people
really were resonating with all of the
foraging videos I was putting
up I love having this yard it's my happy
place so starting actually right here we
have some Violet
leaves violets of course very famous for
making those pretty purple flowers in
the springtime but a lot of people don't
know that their leaves are also a great
leafy green here we have some wood sorl
the seed pods do explode but they are
delicious I'm trying to see if any of
them are ripe enough to oh that one just
did in my hands I ruined it oh that one
is just shooting seeds out right now but
they're tiny so it's hard to see but if
you catch them before they are shooting
seeds out one they look like little
bananas and two they are so tart and
tasty the whole plant is really tart and
tasty but I feel like the mini bananas
are the best let's see what else we have
going on here some black Nightshade
which is currently flowering if you
catch the greens before the plant is
flowering you can cook them and eat them
here we have Spanish needles Biden by
panata which stays really nice and
tender all all summer and I love their
Lacy leaves though it does often get
confused with Ragweed and it kind of
tastes like cilantro and parsley had a
baby so if you're one of the cilantro
soap people maybe stay away from this
one but everyone else should enjoy
it and this is our big old patch of
Lamb's quarters this is chanap podium
Alba white goose foot and I love that we
just have these Lush patches of in the
backyard and if you just keep breaking
off the tender tops they will just keep
growing through the rest of the growing
season though I do let some of them go
to seed so we can get their tasty seeds
to make things like cereal or you can
pop them and add them into dishes like
itty bitty tiny little
popcorns I love being able to come back
here to come eat a snack get a snack
make a snack when I just need to take a
breather in between meetings
being a Creator in Ohio I absolutely
love it because my content is nature
Centric and here I'm a Stones throw away
from the foothills of the Appalachian
Mountains you know I could be at the
great lakes in a couple hours I love
what I have access to living
here I'm usually very hardpressed to
leave like a foraging Excursion with
absolutely nothing just because there's
almost always like greens to be
harvesting or seeds from things to be
harvesting and thankfully we just have
so many Native edible plants here in
this part of
Ohio that as long as you know what to be
looking for you can be finding things
most times of the
year so can you do it everywhere yes
should you do it everywhere no a lot of
especially State Park Parks National
Parks have rules put in place
prohibiting foraging completely or at
least curving it a great
deal if we want to talk about how much
of my diet is foraged food it depends on
the time of year this time of year I can
have entire days when everything that I
am eating is foraged because there's so
much in season both like roughage low
calorie things like lots of different
greens and also some sugary higher
calorie things like
fruit my tagline now I guess somewhat
famously which feels weird to say is
Happy snacking don't die and honestly
when I first started filming foraging
content my partner who is an attorney
was just like you need to remind people
that they need to stay alive and that
foraging as fun as it is is a little
scary sometimes and I really just
thought happy snacking comma don't die
was such a perfect way to encapsulate
that it's still reminding you that what
you're doing can be such a fun joyous
and interesting activity but it is
reminding you to be
careful I am not afraid of eating things
that are poisonous because I don't eat
things unless I'm 100% sure of what they
are and I think that should be
everybody's
[Music]
rule
oh here we have soan I am actually going
to gather a few of these
leaves to cook with our milkweed Buds
and thankfully a few of these leaves
really do go a long way cuz they're huge
in in terms of
[Music]
flavor we're going to go ahead and give
these greens a nice little choer rooni
so we can get ready to blanch them I do
do not have amazing knife skills not
that anybody should be worried that
something terrifying is going to happen
I'm just a slow Chopper so don't judge
me there we
go and now these guys are going to go
into some boiling water so we can give
them a little Blancher roon let's go
ahead and get these guys into the water
oh some of them didn't make it in that's
okay and we're going to go ahead and let
those guys do their thing for about a
[Music]
minute when your ice machine is broken
you use bag
ice there we go and now I'm going to
start scooping these guys up blanching
is great because it kind of breaks down
a little bit of the plant fibers it
makes them this beautiful shade of green
and then plunging them into the ice
water stops them from continuing to cook
so they don't get too
mushy and let me cut the
heat get some of the last of these
greens out there we go let these guys
finish cooling down now I'm going to
take these and ring them out of their
excess water and what we're going to do
with these is get some salt and quick
pickle them cuz they quick pickle like a
dream I'm Olivia and I'm friends with
Alexis I met her during college and
we've just been friends ever
since just here helping her prep with
something that she you know was out and
about and foraging and just make some
tasty snacks sometimes we make full
dinners together and sometimes we just
make you know a little things here and
there so that's what we're doing today
the way I got into foraging was
definitely through Alexis I was not an
outdoorsy person at all you had to like
convince me to go outside and honestly
with foraging you know we kind of
started going together at the start of
the pandemic cuz it was a really Safe
Way for us to hang out cuz we had the
distance we could do it with a mask but
then it was also interesting like for me
there was a point to being outside it
wasn't just to reach the end of a trail
but we got to like Meander and mosy and
like look at different curious things
and we got to have a lot of conversation
about like what could we do with this in
cooking we've cooked together since we
were in college and so being able to
incorporate all of these unique
ingredients and try and see like what
are they adjacent to that's normally
used in the kitchen I found super
interesting and it was nice cuz we just
got to have fun and be able to hang out
in like a very weird time in the
[Music]
world and there we go so what is it it
is some vegan feta mixed with some
foraged wild greens and it is drizzled
with a fermented Juneberry syrup and top
of fermented
juneberries turning a hobby into a
profession is a joy some days and
honestly it's a drag some days some days
I wake up and I'm so excited that I get
to just go outside and be my normal
silly loud curious often hungry self but
some days you don't necessarily want to
be doing the thing you know we all take
breaks from our Hobbies sometimes but
when it's your job sometimes you just
got to do it
anyway I would say honestly my biggest
hurdle has been my own mental health
there are a lot of things about social
media that are ready to push your
buttons we're humans and our silly
little primate brains were literally not
wired to be receiving this much feedback
about
ourselves like ever and certainly not in
a very short period of time so I've just
had to get better at putting up a a
barrier and like honestly getting a bit
of a tougher
skin I love you guys' pink BS I'm so
excited for the juneberries on top so
the drizzle of the Juneberry like
choosing one of the fermented fruit
syrups was a stroke of Genius Olivia oh
I was like I was like you're the one
that wanted something sweet on top I did
not contribute to this when you walk in
you're like you need something
bra NE I don't know what you're making
but put syrup on it
sugar so Alexis on camera like out in
the world Persona versus Alexis at home
Persona are extraordinarily similar
people I would say there is like
95% overlap in that VIN diagram she's
really not that different I think the
same type of jokes the same songs all of
those things are the things that you
definitely see when you hang out with
her and she's an extremely encouraging
person not just on camera but also like
in life I know that's probably why she
has like a lot of friends CU she's just
such a positive person to be around it's
like a ray of sunshine having like a big
personality being able to show that you
know on camera filming herself I think
really plays into like why her content
is so different than other foragers also
like she's always been into the
environment and I believe like even
majored at one point in environmental
engineering I don't think she does this
because she wants to have a career and I
think she does it because she's
[Music]
passionate growing up I knew
culturally that black people were not
known for spending a lot of time in the
Great Outdoors I would go to these
overnight camps in the woods and if I
was lucky there would be another person
of color at camp and when I got to
Junior High School I just remember
especially a lot of the other like black
women in my class being like oh you were
out hiking this
weekend why like B pqu like what were
you doing out there that's not where we
go that's not what we do and it wasn't
until I got older that I realized how
deliberate that was after slavery was
abolished so many laws were put into
place during the Advent of the Jim Crow
era During the Reconstruction Era that
like disincentivized people of color
from a lot of different things one of
which was feeling safe spending time
outdoors and also a lot of those laws
cut off the places where you legally
could be spending time
Outdoors if you were working on a
plantation and you were foraging on that
land before emancipation people weren't
really going to think twice about that
but afterwards especially when some
people of color some indigenous people
black people were thinking oh I can
support myself in my family now with
these
skills a lot of like farmers who now
needed sharecroppers were like
absolutely not cuz if you're making your
own money that way how am I going to get
you back and pay you pennies a day to
share crop on my land that you were
working on for free so what happened is
starting in the South and then kind of
spreading to the rest of the country
really trespass went from being a civil
offense in which maybe you know you'd
get a verbal warning maybe you would get
a small fine to suddenly becoming a
criminal offense in which you could be
doing jail time in which like the fines
would be something that could put a
family under set a family back in ways
that were really
debilitating and if you you didn't own
land then suddenly where were you going
to be
foraging the park system was also at its
Advent in the late 1800s and so suddenly
these huge swaths of land were also
being parceled off and people were being
told you cannot be foraging here even if
you had been foraging here
before and all of those things added
together really over the course of two
generations took these groups of people
who were very used to being very
outdoorsy and having all of these skills
like foraging trapping fishing and
systematically took it away from them
because why put yourself at risk why put
yourself at risk of violence why put
yourself at risk of financial ruin of of
being arrested and then not being able
to find a job and really not being able
to provide for your family it just it
wasn't worth the risk so they stopped
and it doesn't take very long for
generational knowledge to disappear you
know once the last generation that was
practicing it is gone Reclamation
becomes really difficult which is why
when I was naming my page black forager
I was just like I want people to know
that this content is being made by a
black woman but the reason why I want
them to know that is is much
deeper there are now several several
hundred years of us needing to reiterate
that the outdoors are for us
[Music]
too I feel very lucky to have landed in
the community that we landed in there
are a whole lot of initiatives here in
Columbus just in our neighborhood we
have a coalition called Franklinton
Forest which Every Spring any neighbor
that wants one can sign up to get a free
native tree planting in their yard and
this particular neighborhood
historically has been pretty poor a lot
of times especially in lower income or
in previously redlined communities you
see a lack of tree cover and a lack of
canopy directly correlates with higher
temperatures during summer it directly
correlates with more heat related
illness and deaths especially in elderly
people in these neighborhoods and so for
me being able to get more trees into
people's yards especially at no cost is
so
important we also have a local Farm
Cooperative called Franklinton Farms
which took a bunch of the empty lots in
the neighborhood and converted them into
like volunteer heavy farms and you can
can do like a choose your own price Farm
share bag so every week we get produce
that was literally grown within a mile
radius of where we live and we pay the
full amount so that other people who
can't pay the full amount have access to
that fresh
food I am hoping to see more communities
kind of taking hold like of these spaces
and making them more green themselves
cuz a lot of those things are really
hard to legislate on a state or a
federal level but you can enact a lot of
change on a local
level I love being able to do things to
raise funds for some of these different
initiatives like offering foraging
walks I just hope as I get older to be
able to be involved in more of these
types of
projects
[Music]
he